yo what's up guys prestige here i'm
bringing you another minecraft epic sea
for the xbox 360 edition now this one
the seed is rick roll i kid you not
rickroll just like getting Rick road
with rick astley song now you spawn in a
nice little snow pile and I'm here you
got a beautiful ocean mixed with a swamp
which is kind of [ __ ] sexy got on the
edge of the ice you got some lava lakes
burn up some trees this is really I've
looked at this seed a little bit like an
epic man yet insane now and go to check
this out check his little like caverns
peace out that's I'm here there's a
creeper this is beautiful I want to make
a house here I want I want to build my
house in this cavern is mine my house
beat this cavern cuz that would be
amazing and we got more amazing
mountains over here just fly I know I
there we go all right what flying with
glad I now just some awesome awesome
mountains super high up with a better
one 14z where we wait I know up up up up
up up all right down down one year 113
zombies boo member you as zombies
pleasure as you understand that so we
had to this is an awesome see just
bringing you guys to it last seed I
brought with a survival on this is a
little waters epic server that hey if I
want to do a survival I'm gonna put in
red coral because this is awesome we got
some beautiful ice skating in love over
here we were my little pretty princess
well I guess I hope you enjoyed my
name's prestige if you did enjoy leave a
like comment and if you knew subscribe
really helps